what I was so nervous before a holiday
why are you nervous little star
Marseille Martin got a big surprise on
Saturday the 14 year old actress thought
it was just another day at the office
but et had something else in mind I'm
building my own YouTube channel YouTube
is like that's the place where I feel
like people just have these rabid fan
bases why are you looking to any other
YouTube creators to be like like who do
you obsess over I don't know how many
someone's gonna say this in films but I
love I love the Dolans ones oh I've seen
them yes yes I did a thing with James
Charles who did you say you laugh thanks
so much you just got a little closed off
Marseille what's going through your mind
I don't know yes I'm really nervous
right now but I'm good
hi guys we just wanted to say thank you
so much for your support and everything
and you want to place your enemy really
support with everything that you're
doing we're really inspired by you know
everything that you're doing
you know such big things at such a young
age and it's truly a motivational oh my
god okay thank you
hey horse thank you
Wow okay great Wow okay tell me what
what wow nice nursing a WoW means a
bunch of things that's all I could say
right now
did everyone know about this well week
she made us merge like oh wow okay
they're here anything you want to ask
them are say what's one thing oh wow
okay well it's our YouTube channel yeah
yeah
what is the almost like gold you know
I've been in this in a while in what
space like YouTube or just life what do
you say I think just life in general
yeah I mean like right now like YouTube
is so much fun
I'm really really having so much fun
with everything we're doing but uh I
don't I want to do it all
I love like the space that you're in you
know it's awesome no I'm like acting and
everything but I really like enjoy
working behind the scenes as well in
ceiling direction and you say you know
that's I think I know who's gonna be
first class oh my god what I was so
nervous before I walk in here my heart
was like why are you nervous I don't
know the cameras yeah yeah yeah mercy I
like you're like looking back and forth
I'm looking back at voice and I've seen
you're more like but you're also looking
back and forth at them are you taking it
all in right now yes
yeah okay whoa give me some emotions to
describe what you're feeling right now
mmm I'm feeling excited thinking about
all my friends that are like what the
heck
like what's going on Wow another
question how long have y'all been doing
this like YouTube for like four years
oh yeah yeah okay but like videos since
really five just for fun they didn't go
anywhere thank God thank you yeah okay
anything else you want to ask them not
the time
now's the time uh well well no I mean
right I'm missing all right now I'm
stuck great so much
[Music]